what's happening there reject nation we back
at it for the next episode of superman and
lois season two just got renewed for season three
congratulations you guys are a good show hey why
don't you go ahead and check us out on patreon
that's where you'll get the full length reaction
watch along for superman and lois along with
a bunch of other shows that we cover as well
and if you can't do that least you can do is
leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
don't treat it like it's kryptonite especially
that subscribe and notification bell look how i'm
tying it in then prepper boys thanks for helping
us edit it down you guys are so cute let's do it
like your french navigation system
not looking too good it's fine how long was
she out there for hey is it okay to come in
yeah of course oh it's you superman i'm
so happy you can finally come home john
you have no idea lois look all i want to
do is spend time with my two girls you know
what that's not mom she's still gone i know
not the kind of nipple chills i wanted how's your
debate prep coming good emily's been helping me
if you uh you know if you need another opinion or
something no i'm good i'm good forever thank you
probably cheap with your opinions huh yeah they
canceled the season we had to forfeit all the wins
first time in smallville history because of you
damn whose drugs were those no dad you don't
understand no john i don't understand i thought
my son had a little more integrity than this
i'm sure it's about anderson it's perfect timing
as always yeah well this time it actually is
otherwise i would have lasered you
you stopped kello he's gone forget
you killed him i had no choice
backwards name tag we can finally ascend
yeah i know what that means i know what that
means i need you to tell her my other self what
everything you said was true i saw it all i saw me
that's how you become the best version of yourself
by merging with your shadow self get that
shadow work boy she told me to tell you
come now well then we should go and all become
gods god's among us just like the mormons
chris if at any point you feel
uncomfortable i know i'll call you
lois is there a chance to really figure out what's
going on with ally we may not get another one
i gotta go the totally unsuspicious van is here
you sure you want in on this for the story of a
lifetime absolutely put this bag on your headphone
i usually see if you called
lois in your recent history
they're in hazmat suits is that a
problem nope seems totally normal
then get in and put it on in the
way the last suit you'll ever wear
i couldn't hear you did you make a quick game
joke was that what it is it made a minute
so um you guys are just friends now yeah just
friends i was actually kind of hoping that
maybe we could all hang out oh sarah what's
going on i'm following me into my school
i kind of need you to jordan yeah yeah okay
cool i'll i'll message aubry right now all right
i can't wait to meet her and you'll get your
money okay just chill out that's not how this
works hey leave her alone let's get this pendant
so you can figure out a way to destroy it
section 3a clear ew anderson i'm sorry
you're not sorry at all it's time
prep your recorder chrissy anderson knows about
ally when i was locked up with towel i told him
to look into her chrissy's on her way to see
ally right now she said it was something big
i'm tired of feeling incomplete
i finally see the way through
what a weird group chat looks like she's at home
you track lucy's phone do you track my phone
what if they're trying to get into the
inverse world the other superman he came
through a portal in the mines do you think
lucy could be with chrissy and ally the dod
has a security team there let me make a call good
thing you've been reinstated man the upside down
time is finally here oh
i hope you don't incinerate man
this isn't supposed to be happening of course
not the team at the mines isn't responding
whoo just save chris hey
come on no one else matters
oh it's great yeah that hbo money
no
oh god you just had to do it didn't you
we're the only ones that you see that's your
first thought i mean you saw what like how about
god damn thank you it was like something out
of walter guys or stranger stargate i know this
must be strange strange you look exactly like
the guy who killed my mom he's not the same guy
then why do i worry all the time that when he's
around you you're gonna end up just like mom
you should watch season one she's a drug dealer
john jordan she's doing a doubt about her dad okay
it's just the two of them and if they get kicked
out they'll literally have nowhere to go and you
care about it that much you're the only one that
can do something sketch to help their girlfriend
well you've been a part of this since the
beginning there's no one else that could
really help so good excuse to see him you want
one name and she is only a priority to you now
who else was there and deep down deep down
you are so afraid you girls are going to
leave you the same way your wife left
jesus ally oh that i can help you phil
the same way i helped lucy tell me where my
daughter dad dad it's good yeah tap loisen
mirrors reverse uh symbolism
this was lucy's choice she's dad lois no
she's not how are you gonna keep scandaling
i never brought scandal into our house
you did but because i'm a woman this is
now a commentary on me and that's not fair
and it's all because of your stupid mistake
wow now say exactly that maybe you just
needed to get that out of your system just
take a breath you didn't really beat it you know
you're saying stuff you know it's the politics
how you respond to it in the face of a crisis
is it with honesty and integrity because
i will never waver when it comes to trying to
do what's right for my family and for this town
you just got yourself a vote vote lotta for
mayor i love it sorry about nab earlier oh
don't be she uh bit of a [ __ ]
it really tucked some sense into her you did
get hurt helping me and if any of your injuries
these injuries are temporary this can't get back
clear okay yeah there might be a few more moments
of confusion but i'm gonna be okay pretty
soon lois and i will be out of your hair
her me and now will be a family again you'll
have all the time in the world to superman it up
lois there is no way that lucy would go
to another world and only send a text
there's nothing else here i
checked but she can't just leave
oh why didn't they keep leaving me oh
but she wasn't there right i was like
not obviously there i can't just i understand but
he threatened to hurt you if you didn't pay him
your brother heard that you don't have to
worry okay i'm gonna stay over at kim's tonight
can i at least walk you there okay okay and then
after tonight that guy's gonna drop it nice mr
all the way okay good first day can't thank you
sir super first step nothing feels very ominous
about this whole thing hey this is why i love you
even when things are bad you make me laugh love oh
yeah maybe thanks for enabling me john
and there it is the sneakiest truck in all small
get in the car candace she's not
going anywhere hoping you'd see that
oh [ __ ] jordan time to activate your powers
what if jonathan's powers become
activated oh my mind is spinning
oh wow that terrible fall like a fish
good luck finding those now you're dead
oh god damn oh oh boy oh boy
damn except the oliver queen mask
jordan knock his block off all that training
and your little car too look at me ever go
anywhere near her again anywhere that's the name
after you understand yeah yeah okay i stripped the
car for pieces and sell it pay off candace is dead
well natalie i want you to have a
choice including whether or not you
want to get to know me instead of being forced to
live in the same house with me what are you saying
bought you a house an old friend of
mine's had a place for rent for a while
i thought maybe you and your dad could check it
out and then maybe you and i can get to know each
other maybe uh you're living rent-free
get to know it's the least you could do
guys did you look underneath the couch
he's in the cushions
no way we're wearing these suits and it
was dark in the mines so she was there
yeah i guess she got spat back out can i
get you anything are you hungry actually
i'm pretty wiped i just that do you mind
if i of course of course i'll take you home
why don't y'all stay here for the night she's
manipulating you guys to get allie out of the dod
he's just a repair shop i'm sure the
living area is better so he's getting
a spin-off right that's what's happening it
must be john henry chronicles it's perfect
you sure cause clark said that
everything we need is right here
allie didn't have the pendant then who does
jonathan has the bit what took you so long to
get home well i promised candace i would walk
her home no no you are either at the house or at
the store anywhere else you need our permission i
doubt he's lying clark the problem is he's getting
really good at it why don't you just spy on him
just hover above the coins won't know
am i gonna stay in my place tonight i'd love for
you to see it i have fresh ice cream you you used
to dad are you okay he's he'd been drugged
you know god told you she's the bizarro lucy
it's functional lucy bizarro
loosely something in my teeth
yeah sorry i was sort of the fail safe in
case things didn't go according to plan uh why
to make sure ally gets to the other side
i should have called that yeah you couldn't
have seen that coming it's not possible
they duped us all
you see i said i said that about her in her
sarcastic way with the tone in case i was wrong
safeguarding it's discarded that way if i'm
wrong it's just greg was making a joke i'm
right fred got a theory correct it's called the
sarcasm escape hatch that's right the cowards lie
there's so many bad guys hmm and they're all
closing in so many bad guys i think they're
going to break out morgan edge and they're going
to fight the baddies together morgan edge might
sacrifice himself in the end but then he's a good
guy yeah ultimately yeah for brother brother i
think that's what's gonna happen i'm just calling
it and lately my commented skills had been
that's me hitting the target with an arrow so yeah
that was uh that was that was good it was good
another good episode terrific episode fantastic
stuff as always what's your favorite part john
favorite part favorite part of the whole
episode my favorite scene was probably
uh with jonathan and jordan on the
highway tbh i mean it was just very
gratifying to watch jordan have to spring
into action use his powers i like the kind of
tearing down of the wall between the two of
them that's happened they've still got a lot
of tension between john and the parents and
you know all that stuff clark giving him the
cold you know treatment and everything but to
see the way that he and jordan are slowly kind
of coming back together and starting to behave
like brothers again and jordan's helping him out
and he makes that sacrifice and he doesn't make
a huge deal out of it like it was it was a moment
that made me appreciate just how far we've come
with those two we come far with everybody but i
i really uh i don't know for whatever reason
that really stuck out to me in an episode full of
a lot of lovely little character beats and
moments and whatnot you know they never lose sight
of the emotional beats you know amid all
the science fictiony stuff but yeah you know
in the array of things you kind of know were
gonna happen uh that was a nice development
and uh yeah it's just gratifying to watch
him kick a little bit of ass and use his pal
like i love the way that it seems like jordan's
powers are specifically attuned to things having
to do with his brother um and you could argue that
maybe that's a plot device and a mechanic uh but
for the way it's presented here i've actually kind
of enjoyed that sort of extra bond of brotherhood
that it seems like uh jordan's powers kind of
manifest there and and the way in which john
has looked out for him so much over time now he's
looking out for him in a way that feels less like
he's trying really hard and more like he's just
you know actually looking out for him and so uh
so yeah that was that was perhaps my favorite
moment in the episode worried for for the boy for
standing up uh sarah and uh and her friend it's
a bummer it's definitely gonna uh you know create
some friction with their relationship but uh yeah
i like the tension coming out of that as well that
whole thing about like i had to sneak back here i
wasn't gonna tell them you know it's nice i mean
that one guy you gotta hope that he doesn't uh
you know rat out john uh jordan for having actual
kryptonian power uh although i guess he could have
just assumed it was xk but you know it seemed like
it was clear to him that it was a bit more serious
than that so uh you know i'm a little worried that
that is gonna lead to some kind of thing where he
gets exposed or whatever but uh yeah that was a
very solid sequence what was your favorite part of
the episode i don't think a guy knows i was jordan
that hood really is a very effective face
covering this guy clearly hasn't seen
some cw shots of course sorry i know oliver
queen yeah yeah the hood the hood's enough
there's a reason he had his hood on of course
because yeah it's an impenetrable disguise
in a world where all clark has to do is take
his glasses on and off i'm pretty sure he's
disgusting that's true absolutely but now that's
what jordan needs now is he's gonna have to get a
pair of groucho glasses or something to to really
disguise himself what are you doing at my house
shortage don't don't ever put
those glasses on in here yet
without preparing us that was a really rewarding
scene it's the most exciting scene i like
everything they're doing with lana i'm really i'm
really happy with how they're flushing that out
it feels the most disconnected from all the other
stories though weirdly because she has this whole
plot of like running for mayor and then this
fallout with her husband yet it's kind of like
not tied into everything else that's happening
but the way they're developing it is really
really engaging and i think they're fleshing out
a really strong character for lana on handling
a separation handling a divorce and knowing
how to comment on situations like real life
things that happen like divorces are so common if
i'm not mistaken 79 of marriages and in divorce
only 21 success rate so you're seeing what
79 percent of married couples go through
and this that's an actual statistic i want
everyone to take me seriously on that as possible
uh i think that the way yeah they're handling
hers is really awesome the way the men write
her character it's really good i don't know
who the writers are it's a matter of it to be
honest i really don't know um and uh it's a that
relationship is fascinating like it was a real
like nuanced beat when she found out that he
got his own place or something that feels more
real and tangible about oh this is we're really
separated you know it's like that kind of thing
where you're you're in that separation phase and
you still feel like connected or there's a chance
subconsciously you know i imagine that's partly
why you pick up on more nuanced details of her
performance of like the fact that she invited
kyle back in for this subconsciously reads to
me as like well she still wanted to be around him
she still wanted to connect with him and talk with
him maybe use some of this as an excuse to air
out some stuff you know the way how some things
did manage to penetrate through so i really
love what they're doing with her especially
in terms of our other players uh i think
everything's pretty solid you know i like
the tension with um there's some stuff that i i'm
not a big fan of like i i'll get to that i love
the way they realize going to the they call it the
other side here it's always something so basically
the other is the inverse inverse world first
world or something like that yeah it's always
something so basic with these like you know
parallel backward topia yeah reverse land river
yeah yeah uh with going to to that i thought
the way they visually realized that was awesome
um some of the rules were a little muddy to me so
it's like do you need the pendant to cross over is
that why anderson was able to successfully cross
over while everyone else was like oh god what's
happening to me incinerated [ __ ] but ally was
also like oh [ __ ] i just now supposed to go
what's going on here no no no no that was uh
that was i'm curious on what the motives are here
i'm kind of worried this season
like as great as this episode was
a few nitpicks are there um which i could rattle
off in a second i'm a little worried this season
might not stick the landing as strong as the first
season because there's there's so many pieces here
there's so many things happening it's like who's
the real back well it all come together in the end
you know like you have anderson you had bizarro in
the first half and really it's ali that's about it
it's really just a lot of it but even when like
it elevated anderson to like i'm the real i had
a plan and manipulate and get to the top here of
this world i just learned about like a day ago
um like i i don't know what's going on there
is it is it the alley in the inverse world
who manipulated him into doing that you know
um is is the real baddie the inverse alley so
just seems like there's a lot going on and i'm
kind of wondering if all like coalesce that we
gotta deal with like lucy's stupid predictable [
__ ] and that annoys me it does it was like it was
pretty uh it was like so remarkably predictable
on how that was all gonna go like she's not really
dead we didn't see it happen they're mourning
over nothing great acting in those scenes
fantastic acting love lois in the apartment
being like i'm looking everywhere i've looked
in this bookshelf i've looked at this phone i
don't know where she is and clark hug me hold
me love me that was a really great scene even
uh papa and papa lane breaking down about the
whole situation was really really good like
but him going into the interrogation room
like come on dod be smarter than that would be a
bunch of [ __ ] morons what happened if they're
too close to this case you know don't they say
that in movies and shows usually when you're like
a police department but you think a dod would be
smarter to be like you're too close to this case
well yeah and also too i mean i i thought that
while it's well within character for ali to be
able to get under his skin because of the personal
connection i was also like she got to you really
fast yeah yeah you should have did this yeah
so i thought that was a little like like i
get it you're doing it for the dramatic effect
and it was ultimately nitpicky because what do
i want some like boring ass scene of them sitting
behind the glass watching some dude i don't know
interrogate her no every doll would be boring um
so it's like i'd rather have this scene than that
inverse however uh yeah it just like kind of
pulls me out a tad bit but i'm like come on
man get her [ __ ] together lucy predictable sarah
and you're going through divorce with your parents
you're kind of annoying though sometimes man i
gotta say like you're kind of annoying even the
way you approach jonathan about like you just try
to understand me and where i'm coming from and my
thing and i can't help but be annoyed like i know
i'm supposed to i know i know what you defenders
and your little comment boxes are saying of how
she's a girl and you know it's like i've said
some stupid [ __ ] in my life too when i was
younger i studied stupid stuff this day that
gets me in trouble at the same time you know i'm
just giving you my honest feeling and my honest
feeling when she says that is god that's [ __ ]
annoying you're like this is don't you understand
that in john and jordan's eyes that's who you
cheated on him with there's no other way to put
it into a different perspective he dropped that
[ __ ] pretty fast for you and now you're like
yeah she's the only girl who's ever been divorced
and who's ever had divorced parents so i'm gonna
be friends with her like find someone else
in this school that you can maybe talk to
um really fair i mean yeah it is a little
bit like i i suppose you could liken it to
like uh i don't know uh lana or yeah lana being
like hey kyle let's go get lunch with tonya
you know like let's go get get food with or
let's meet up with the person you cheated with
i mean obviously uh lana saying that to kyle i'm
not gonna get the the motivations right there but
it's basically akin to having the three of them
all get lunch together is what you're saying is
like you know it's yeah it's the person that you
cheated with and now you want me to make nice
uh even though it's not quite as advanced degree
as you know like a six-month affair or whatever
kyle had but but yeah there is a little bit
of uh i don't know i i i this episode hit me
the first time this show has hit me with a sense
that while i still really enjoyed all the scenes
i felt like the scenes were getting like really
short like there were a lot of really short scenes
they're still good at making the dialogue
feel natural and the performances are still
really solid in those scenes but i feel like a
moment like that could have had some more nuance
or something on top to maybe uh i don't know
alleviate that because i don't begrudge them
the whole thing about like this girl is like you
know we were super close before and uh and then
you know this kiss thing and then we just split
apart because that now we're you know like getting
back together and then making friends again but
yeah i mean like there is a certain aspect of
like you know jordan whatever you're feeling
about it just just stow it you know where uh
yeah we could do with the little uh i don't know
she went to meet with her without even telling him
messed up bottom line cheated she cheated and
she met with the person to almost destroy that
situation almost destroyed their relationship sure
yeah there's no shirt this is just his objective
this is what happened in the show did you not
see the show that's what happened in the show
yeah it's all in the chat it's
all there count it it's all fair
so yeah and then she just approaches him like
hey i did this and i kind of expect you to be
cool with me going to lunch now i want you to
come and come to dinner i wonder if that will
boil over at some point or come back around
or if jordan is just going to be the best guy
about it probably hey and you know some of
you guys might get mad at me for saying that
[ __ ] but i remember when that whole thing was
happening with like lana talking with sarah in
the garage being like he doesn't deserve you
if he won't take you back i remember when that
was happening i saw all them comments you guys
mean like yo [ __ ] lana and this is i hate how
the show just expects me to forgive sarah so
fast i haven't forgotten i ride that anger and
ride those rage clicks that's how you
guys come here to superman and lois yeah
right rage against sarah yeah that's why you guys
come here i get it i'm baiting you in with that 10
minutes sarah ran i don't really give a [ __ ] do
whatever she wants i support her in fact actually
you have to tell jordan who cares she should just
have two relationships completely oblivious to
one another if she didn't have powers if he didn't
have powers he wouldn't take two if she take three
she does not know he has powers so she could
just put this all behind his back because just
gotten smooth sailing like nothing man could
even kept hooking up with her that's right
sarah's an idiot that's where this [ __ ] is yeah
there's an idiot we need sarah to become euphoria
cop on you for you on season two yet yes right
just binged at all all of it where are you on you
for you uh the menu of the hbo max app how can you
say become euphorio if you haven't seen euphoria
john because the only thing people talk about in
relationship to uh euphoria is like the abundance
of like pulpy uh sexual material so i can only
assume that uh that's if you're a freaking pansy
which i am and you gotta look away i am i do
otherwise i would have given euphoria pg rating
because we just censor our kids too much yeah
it should be on freaking channel sev abc abc is
your family for you teach your kids some [ __ ]
once in a while yeah yeah yeah anyway guys do you
think sarah should keep on cheating leave your
thoughts down below thanks for being here yes
john henry and natalie moved out too i don't you
if you're cool with everything i'm not really that
pissed i'm just you're going to turn the camera
off and go back and just oh glower these people
trying to forgive this [ __ ] oh yeah natalie
man you know grumpy grumpy natalie well that's
something where i felt like that could have been
as as much as i can appreciate the performers i'm
like if they had maybe made that back and forth
like the main subplot of an episode or something
like that uh you know i mean it's like nice to
see her out not nice but you know like it does
something it gives an effect to her emotional
state to see her stranded out in space and all
that stuff but i feel like if that had really
if this had really been again it's like you said
there's so many things going on that it doesn't
feel as as much of a like a tuned in wrap around
as it could have if this episode like really kind
of honed in on oh john's back and then natalie's
having this you know struggle it sort of feels
like this thing that's been kind of happening as
a sidebar for the past several episodes that
now finally got kind of pushed forward but
all i got from what you said was that you
seem to have more qualms with that than with
sarah wanting jordan to meet up with the person
she cheated on him with like somehow you just
rattle off a whole bunch of issues with that
without taking even a second to go you know i kind
of get where natalie's coming from and i like that
they explored why absolutely a lot of her grudging
behavior came from and when like oh that's
why she would behave like she has a stick up
harassment and it makes a lot of sense totally you
know when you think about it but boom just only
problems only problems with that but the second
i say something about sarah you're like yeah i
guess sure maybe yeah oh whatever yeah that's fine
like yeah yeah so it's extremely [ __ ] up so well
whatever around yeah it's kind of fun i hope sarah
dies in the next episode thanks because sarah
sarah's actually half white jordan you can
pick that car up and just drop it on her
that's too far do you learn how
to forget people once in a while
all right guys thanks for being here
and uh we'll catch you guys soon